[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
steria va tuer et bing
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
aucun témoin
parfois c'est bien toi ville qui
dernière comme ça en sera quitte il faut
qu'on les écrase quoi pour les aura
cette fois j'étais papa à faire ce que
je fais quoi un truc important affirmé
vient on fait la belle brestois pas
vache mais pour moi excusez moi non mais
bien merde pour moi
excusez moi je faisais pas très bien
compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi
puis toujours aussi dangereux
[Applaudissements]
mais je te prends comme coéquipier quand
tu voudras
de la berd au et
c'est toi qui viens avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un break pendant tel effet ça fait de
faire la une de tous les canards de
langue anglaise
même si l'adversaire ni d'accrochages
félicitations je vous remercie et
affectation au choix ce que vous voulez
où vous voulez on les a changés qu'est
ce qui vous intéresse
j'avais envie d'être instructeurs comme
en
attente guen
exact
seigneurie pitié est prêt pour le combat
mavericks promenade de santé pour chaque
avancée
contacts multiples cibles ainsi cinq
visuels de nautique on dirait que ça
s'éloigne et au visuel taleo 23 deux
heures je prends avec moi
je suis fière et m'a coupé la route
pour partie au cimetière soit chaud bon
allez chemin dans ton cul on est trop
d'eau non plus trop bas dont les
missiles je pense canaux
les choix étaient au dégage
regardera putsch mais l'âge de faire un
shoot il me faut encore 20 secondes ce
qu'on dit c'est bon
engagé en cage
avec sa patiente elle exploite la vie
ajoute encore dix secondes et c'est bon
iceman également favori iceman des gages
à droite c'est bon pour moi encore cette
seconde phase i com rapportait ce soit à
moi dieu ou vers ajouté bernard
simple
on arrête on adore votre match
pas tant que ça
away qui va en voir
perte de contrôle c'est pas moi c'est
pas bon ménage mais d un bruit qu'un
pépin il est envoyé blanc il se dirige
dans la merde
je suis pas quelqu un en avant j'y
arrive pas j'en paie la poignée
déjections
que tu nous as he has j'avais pas choper
la poignée éjection hectares
j'ai
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
gauche non
prenez vous
non mon dieu
où
[Musique]